all right everyone we are with Naveen
Jane we're gonna be talking about all of
the nuance of the microbiome and this is
a very complex place you're saying
earlier there's about two million or so
genetic expressions that come from the
different bacterial waters there
bacteria Quietus is a nice and a fungus
and mold and all the good stuff Wow okay
and is it majority bacteria and then the
rest is the virus is yeast mold and
fungus Wow
first I want to point up your t-shirt I
just love that microbial t-shirt
shoutout yeah I'm just selling those we
we got them with Davey doing Duncan and
arc fusion and we are we love the shirts
that have like powerful messages like
what is the microbiome why are you
wearing that and you know get to start
the conversation what listen now let's
look at these at that you know the
microbiome what it is and you know most
people are just like oh my God all these
yucky stuff icky stuff is not inside our
gut
should we just kill them all and that's
really is what has been essentially the
modern health care has raised the war
against these organisms without
realizing they are our allies but for
them he won't be alive in fact if you
kill the microbiome microbiome will kill
you nice I'm sorry however if you don't
have microbiome you cannot live it so
our human DNA is needed for us to be
born but our microbiome is what keeps us
healthy and alive right when you go out
and take antibiotics you're throwing a
nuclear bomb inside your body killing
everything and what are we a hundred
percent totally that is that is the
Society of consensus yeah
antibiotics why are we being prescribed
them then if this is a nuclear bomb so
interestingly is our modern health care
system was developed at a time when we
were all dying from infectious diseases
so those were the communicable diseases
that people were catching infraction and
in those days it was needed because
there was no
nothing else you could do so they did a
broad-base nuclear bomb right as opposed
to trying to figure out what is what
bacteria is infectious how do we get rid
of that and they said let's just hold
the bomb and let's kill all of them
right and that's literally what we did
so there is no more precision medicine
it was like boom everyone bad right now
what's interesting thing is if you look
at today our medicine is fundamentally
designed to keep you sick so hang on for
a second I'm gonna stop for a second
here let's go back to the microbiome
what is microbiome the microbiome is
really the set of organisms that are in
symbiotic relationship with humans with
humans period yes right now these
organisms work with our immune system
they work from the time the kids that
the child is born in fact now they are
saying that even inside the womb
amniotic fluid is not sterile in fact
the placenta or the cord is not sterile
infant the mother's microbiome now has
been proven impacts the child and it's
even said chances of autism so the
research that came out two weeks ago
that talked about a child's development
directly influenced by the mother's
mother's microbiome during pregnancy so
during so they actually published a
study that shows how mother's microbiome
during pregnancy impacts the chances of
the kid getting autism are we talking a
of those my Crozier describing
microorganisms are then forming into the
child's microbiome yeah so basically the
two things happen inside that there is a
lot of what I would say still not a
consensus around does the microbiome in
get in the child while the child is
still in the womb or does it the first
exposure happens when the child is going
through the birth canal we all agree
that the massive amount of microbiome
exposure happens when the child is going
through the birth canal
right so during the birth canal the
child is inhaling the thing child is
being you know put all over the
microbial our microbial stuff and during
the breastfeeding not only the mother's
milk is provides the microbiome and the
antibodies in fact the first couple of
days of the mother's breast milk has
colostrum that colostrum cannot be
digested by the human body period it is
only there to be feeding the microbiome
so imagine what the nature is saying I
just created the offspring the best way
to keep the offspring healthy is not to
feed it but to feed them
that means if I can feed the microbiome
make them grow and get them to train the
immune system that offspring will be the
healthiest so think for a second they
are the king for us to stay healthy in
fact when we are born we have very poor
immune system our microbiome constantly
trains are immune system in fact the
children who take antibiotics when their
baby they get higher chances of getting
eczema allergies and all kinds of other
chronic diseases in fact even the babies
that are born through c-section again
I'm not suggesting that the c-section is
horrible and I'm not blaming mothers it
many times
that's life-saving yes but a lot of the
times people are now using them as for
convenience but in China 50% of the
birth are through c-section drives right
zero what and the reason is because they
want the thing to be born at it it it
and this auspicious time and they go out
and get a c-section or is it it's about
the alignment of planets
yes stars yeah and they don't realize
that they are essentially denying the
human body the child the experience of
going through the birth canal that gives
them the exposure to the microbial right
so all I can say is that microbiome is
the most important thing it is there is
no good bacteria or a bad bacteria that
is the old philosophy of good and bad
it's really about a good
ecosystem or a bad ecosystem there is no
such thing as one unique healthy microbe
and your microbiome ecosystem is
different than my microbiome ecosystem
but what percentage are we talking like
in terms of difference at this if you
look at the screen level less than 5% is
same between any two people when you
look at our human DNA 99% is same
between every any two people yes so you
and I share even though he looks so
different
I mean 99% the same but my neighbor I
was about 95 percent different different
different 5% same oh my gosh and that's
the key and interestingly think of our
microbiome as a rainforest every step
you take in the rainforest is a
completely different ecosystem yet every
part of it is lush and green that means
you and I can have a both have healthy
microbiome without it being the same so
it's not like there is one healthy
microbiome we all can have healthy
microbiome there can be different and
here's the reason because we multiple
organisms can produce exactly the same
thing
so you can have an organism a I can have
organism B and someone can have an
organism C they both pretty all three of
them can be producing nutrient like
butyrate right interesting I am or they
could be producing things that are
harmful and they could all be different
yeah what you're trying to and what you
mean it depends on what they're paired
with in the ecosystem it's the whole
ecosystem we all is going to come in a
surprise we all have equal i we all have
seed if it is just that everything
around it it's keeping it in check check
right if we don't have any of the things
like cedar for e.coli our immune system
is kind of dormant then you want to keep
the immune system little bit primed for
it to be ready to act when it's needed
yeah so these guys keep the immune
system let you know on their toes
and the good guys keep these guys in
check to make sure that in god of
control yeah this this is this big
difference in microbiomes this kind of
will lead us into what you're working on
with volume but how can we possibly get
this ninety five percent difference
between microbiomes that that just seems
like there's so much to actually need to
compute and understand about it to
understand what how I can keep my gut
ecosystem healthy and that is something
we're gonna talk next about is that now
we have the technology to do that until
now we couldn't do that and that's the
reason why the science of microbiome
never advanced because the technology
just wasn't there right in good old days
used to culture the bacteria and when
you're culturing you only bacteria that
we could grow on the battery dish is the
only one we saw without realizing large
percentage of the bacteria that are
growing inside our gut are all anaerobic
that means as soon as they hit the
oxygen they're dead right so we could
culture them so we never thought they
existed like and technology is now
advancing and that's something I think
we should talk next about yeah oh my
gosh
so anaerobic anaerobic cultures you can
grow a lot of interesting micro oh yes
yeah okay cool that's been a good
section on the nuance of the microbiome